in stone holes they burn their great
fires in stone holes they Forge their
sharp Spears whilst I walk alone in the
mountains with no true companion but
tears giants exist among the oldest of
races in Westeros but evidence of them
can be found throughout the world of Ice
and Fire
Joe Gwyn is the Dothraki name for the
stone giants of legend in northern esos
these great beasts were said to be twice
the size of the giants of Westeros they
lived in the realm of the neocon a
mountainous region within the
northernmost part of the CRA's axis qua
the land north east of the Dothraki holy
city Vaes Dothrak south east lies the
howling hills were the last of the Jew
Qin fought and lost in a battle against
the Jew boasts nigh the Joe Quinn were
never seen again
and are soon to be extinct in caves
beneath the hills of your voz just
southeast of Braavos the bones of giants
who want to live there can be found
northwest of the city norvos exists a
vast cave system which is considered to
be one of the natural wonders by lamas
long Strider the famous scribe and
traveler and according to legend it is
the entrance to the underworld in the
Velvet hills just northeast of Pentos
there is a deep lake and circles of
standing stones said to have been raised
by the Giants and lastly on the island
of Abe the largest of the even island
nation giants were said to once roam
though they have not been seen for many
eons here
there are also mammoths that roam in the
great Hills and some say that even
unicorns which have long since gone
extinct in Westeros can be found in the
higher mountains
here although humanoid the giants of
Westeros are described as far more than
simply large men Giants are covered by a
shaggy Pelt of fur that grows thicker
below their waist as they age their fur
becomes gray and streaked with white
their heads are thrust forward from
their shoulder blades they have squashed
in the faces with square teeth and tiny
eyes and it's olds of horny flesh their
eyesight is poor and they snuffle
constantly smelling as much as they see
the lower torsos of giants are half
again as wide as their upper torsos
their chests are sloped and their arms
hang lower than those of men their legs
are short and in in splayed horny feet
that need no shoes even in the coldest
of weather like the dwarves of token
mythology it is said that female giants
are difficult to distinguish from males
for they also have beards little is
known of the culture of the giant they
are Shia creatures though they are
hostile towards men giants like men bury
their dead even some believe that the
king of the Giants is buried in the
great borrow a large grassy hill
surrounded by the Barrow lands in the
far north of Westeros instead of the
king of the first men though some
legends that men have about giants paint
them as bloodthirsty monsters one one
who possesses the strength of twelve men
is shy and passive and would only attack
if provoked one one is also a vegetarian
the children of the forest coexisted
with the giant for thousands of years
before the first men arrived in Westeros
though they occasionally quarreled they
lived together in red
it is said that the Giants also fiercely
protect their animals such as the
mammoths they use a feed this may
explain why the Giants are hostile
towards men it is well known that
several species were hunted to
extinction by the first men after their
arrival in Westeros the Giants like the
children of the forest coexisted with
nature without destroying it this is a
direct conflict of culture beyond the
wall the free folk sing a song of the
last Giants and how men destroyed their
Kingdom I am the last of the Giants my
people are gone from the earth the last
of the great mountain Giants who ruled
all the world at my birth oh the small
folk have stolen my forests they've
stolen my rivers and hills and they've
built a great wall through my valleys
and fished all the fish from my rills
mankind's inability to coexist with
nature is a repetitive theme throughout
a Song of Ice and Fire the Giants are
just another example of a species hunted
to near-extinction by mankind and
painted as the aggressors by their
legends for it is always the victors
that write history
you
you